hey youtubers it's Charlie so big news
there is a Doctor Who spin-off that the
BBC just confirmed that's coming 2017
it's called class just Doctor Who class
it's all about coal Hill School what
they're calling it is a why a series as
an young adult and they cite Buffy
is in Joss Whedon's Buffy in Hunger
Games so think of it is like a Doctor
Who show for a much much younger
audience without them having to go super
kissy-face with future doctor castings
right now doctor who has a fairly broad
audience but they don't have a big
presence in like really really young
kids and that's what they're looking for
they're looking for the Hunger Games
audience really the way to do that is to
make a show all about the kids so if
Peter Capaldi was to be in that he would
be like a background player even though
his role in the narrative might change
the doctor is always gonna be the main
star of his own show so they'll have the
main series that can be nice and dark
they can cast crazy drama make it as
nuts as they want and then they can do
this other show that will skew way way
younger an even better example might be
like a Hogwarts show where the kids
actually go out and fight monsters in
the real world Steven Moffat actually
referenced modern-day Britain and
monsters in his quote about the show and
whether you think it's a good thing or
whether you think it's a bad thing
Steven Moffat isn't really going to be
associated with this new spin-off show
it's gonna be like Torchwood it'd be
like it's own separate thing although to
be honest Torchwood somatically was
actually more of an adult show it was
like you know take the family doctor who
show and then make a version of that
that's just for adults with like super
adult themes so this is skewing in the
Hogwarts Harry Potter direction now the
person that's gonna be running the show
the person is actually gonna be
developing this is Patrick Ness you may
or may not be familiar with him he will
be working with Brian mentioned and
Steven Moffat in the in the Doctor Who
universe because it will be connected to
the main show but just like Sarah Jane
and Torchwood they're largely going to
exist on their own they might do like
one big crossover per year and then like
a couple other small references to each
other but they haven't announced any
casting so I have no idea if they're
going to be casting high school-aged
kids or if it's gonna be 20-something
kids acting like high school kids we'll
see I think just because they've
mentioned Hunger Games in the news
released so many times the actors that
they cast will be comparable to the age
of the actors in Hunger Games and just
for reference this is actually going to
be airing on BBC three they're the ones
that commissioned it they're going to
start shooting next year in 2016 and
then it's
supposed to be premiering in 2017 so
it's gonna be a little while before we
see it but if you live in Wales and you
do like to go to film sets then you
might have a chance to see them filming
stuff right now it's looking like it's
gonna be eight episodes that are 45
minutes each for the first series let me
know in the comments what do you guys
think about a new Doctor Who spin-off
that isn't Torchwood and everybody want
to Torchwood to come back it still could
at a certain point but obviously they'd
have to cast some new actors John
Barrowman said that he's totally happy
to come back and play Captain Jack again
but he thinks that Steven Moffat
probably isn't going to ask him just
because Steven Moffat run is all about
the stuff that Steven Moffat did
although he is bringing back a lot of
old stuff like Davros isn't something
that he created for those of you that
really like it when they bring back old
stuff he actually did say Steven Moffat
actually said that he's trying to find a
way to bring k9 back apparently he
wanted to bring it back during the
series night Christmas special during
the the last Christmas episode but it
just it didn't fit in k9 actually does
invoke a lot of sarah-jane thought so
you know very prominent spin-off for a
couple of years but most of my
experience with Doctor Who spin-offs has
been with Torchwood like that was like
my go-to series after Doctor Who I think
my favorite year that was actually
Series three children of earth and it
also featured Peter Capaldi although he
wasn't my favorite part of that he's
just the story of that felt a lot
stronger than Miracle Day which was
series for that was actually like a
co-production with the US company John
Barrowman did say that Torchwood is
coming back but it's only going to be a
radio play they're giving it like the
Big Finish treatment but you will get
John Barrowman Captain Jack again so if
you're really big fan of the radio
dramas then at least you'll have that
there have been some rumors that the BBC
isn't gonna have enough funding to do
Doctor Who next year so they might only
do a special or they might wait till
2017 to do series 10 I don't know
anything about that that's just a rumor
at this point but feel free to speculate
in the comments this is really like a
problem that's just affecting Great
Britain right now it's just because it's
funded publicly like when we watch into
international countries the BBC usually
doesn't see a lot of that money I don't
think they would greenlight a spin-off
series if they weren't gonna do the main
series so I don't think there's too much
to worry about
there will at least be some form of new
Doctor Who next year with the new
companion which actually reminds me
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner Lizzie Dunn you win a $20 Amazon
gift card just be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I get your contact info I'll start a
new round of the giveaway whenever I
post my episode 3 video on sad
while you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for my episode 2 video
ant you can click here to learn all
about the northern Lords and Game of
Thrones thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight